Welcome to the Law Faculty.
I want to start my first lecture by asking a simple question.
What is law?
That's a very simple question, isn't it?
We all know the answer, don't we?
Let's see.
We know that the law provides a set of rules...
...that allows people to live in an organized and civilized way.
If someone breaks a rule, there's a system of punishment...
...that not only protects people...
...but also provides a deterrent.
That is, it deters or stops people from breaking the rule.
Okay.
But what are these rules and who decides what they are?
For example, most people would agree that you should wash your hands before you eat a meal.
If you don't, have you broken the law?
In my household, my mother imposed this rule and if any of the children broke it,...
...they were punished.
But has someone who hasn't washed their hands before dinner broken the law?
Well.
Yes and no, or it depends.
So what is law?
What is the intrinsic meaning of the word?
A word that we use every day and think we understand.